c'est la première fois depuis près de 60
ans que l'iran demande l'aide urgente du
fonds monétaire international une
demande faite par courrier vendredi
dernier mais annoncé ce jeudi 28
la directrice générale du fmi a déclaré
que les pays affectés par l'épidémie de
kobe de 19 serait soutenu par
l'intermédiaire de l'instrument de
financement rapide
notre banque centrale a demandé un accès
immédiat cette facilité le conseil
d'administration du fmi doit rester
fidèle au mandat du fonds être du bon
côté de l'histoire et agir de façon
responsable
téhéran veut obtenir du fmi à près de 5
milliards de dollars pour lutter contre
le coronavirus particulièrement virulent
dans le pays
mais il ya peu de choses que
l'organisation monétaire répondent
positivement à la demande iranienne
problème aucune décision ne peut être
prise par le fonds monétaire
international sans l'aval de washington
et on le sait les états unis mènent
actuellement une politique de pression
maximale contre téhéran dans le dossier
du nucléaire iranien le président
américain cherche à assécher les
finances de la république islamique et
rien ne montre jusque là une volonté de
donald femme de l'infléchir conséquence
téhéran ne peut plus utiliser ses
propres fonds bloqués dans les banques
internationales
d'ailleurs dans une autre lettre
adressée au secrétaire général des
nations unies le chef de la diplomatie
iranienne a demandé la levée immédiate
de toutes les sanctions américaines
contre l'iran
l'un des principaux foyers du
coronavirus dans le monde ces derniers
jours les autorités du pays ont
multiplié les mesures drastiques pour
contrôler l'épidémie
les iraniens sont invités à rester chez
eux et vite et ne voyagez à travers tout
le territoire
[Musique]